what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we thought we were gonna watch Mario
today because we mistakenly thought it came out
as Early Access but Amazon Prime was misleading
explaining the outfits but we're gonna watch
Jack reach her episode six instead even better
I say so guys you know what to do leave a like
for John for all the hard work he does around
here do it for John put in the comment box as
your favorite thing about John Reacher over
here go ahead and do it also subscribe click the
notification Bell to see John react to episode 7
of Jack Reacher the TV series hey thank you to
all who have already joined our patreon page
become super sexy rejects for this show alone
but we also cover so many things exclusively
over their reaction highlights and watch alongs
included for John guys let's get into it for John
and the handiwork done to kleiner's neck it's
clear the South Americans are from Venezuela
damn Dutch angle that's a Venezuelan
butterfly cut makes usf68 bleed out
simultaneously so you effectively drown
in your own blood and you can't learn
it anywhere else when's the last time
you were on a Stakeout climb a compound
change in leadership can result in mistakes if
it does I want to be watching when it happens
plan everyone in town knows mine and you're a
Bentley is in subtle it was a Bentley stupid
this is Station House the dong has
officially had the fan just curse Finley
now I wanna go eat at jolene's
now where was he found office
secretary discovered him this morning okay
assume County forensics are already there
hey buy anything nothing yet not my fingerprints
or anything and a hair my dad's guilty you're
a piece of [__] easy nice you're trying to
Sully the name and reputation of a man who has
done nothing but gift to this community I know
you're emotional and I'm sorry for your loss KJ
but I've never done anything in this town but
my job KJ totally murdered him Thief kill his
dad next in line for the throne a little Joffrey
over here I think KJ did it hold off going to the
crime scene just hit you accuse this town's fairy
Godfather of homicide only to find out he's a
victim like all the others he could be both sure
so hit the bench I'll call you back in the game
soon enough is he using NBA analogies because
he's black that's right man that's the only way
he thinks he can get through to him that's why
he doesn't want him to go to the crime scene and
get accidentally arrested for being black hmm good
guy he's a real hero just need the windows tinted
three days at least I guess I'll need a loner
then yeah we don't do lovers what do you do
guess you can take my car by the time being it
ain't a Bentley but uh it'll get you from A to B
oh God it's like to cover that Black
Keys album how's she doing Mr Mosley
stay here why should I let anyone drive me
from my town only way they're pushing me and
my sister out is in caskets foreshadowing
why you ever came here in the first place
my Grave's a long way from Harvard Square
detecting city boy that's the new business
his wife is living here and he's stalked her
I'm gonna inquire about your personal life
but if you inquire about mine it's none
of your goddamn business you hanging on
I'm hanging on past red hope you know how to play
Settlers of Catan it's Board Game Central in here
let's go this place was used for Mob witness once
door's been reinforced good alarm system but use
your instincts you feel any danger you grab that
family and you run just put them on your back
beef jerking in an enclosed space protein
iron sink doesn't spike your insulin
love jerky that's all I eat jerk Reacher
some missed marketing opportunity right there
so what's the deal with the 110. Army let me
put together my own special investigations unit
there were nine of us there are the rest of them
no idea pretty cool barely talk to your brother
for years fall out of touch with your army Buddies
how do you let go of people so easily you don't
it's not healthy you're one to talk move on Finley
I've seen trees lose Rings faster than you
as a bar my wife's dead
well I feel bad about that joker
no matter a lot of a lot of jokes
is that why you left Boston you try living in
a city where every place you look some memory
of the love of your life all
the kick in the gut oh yeah
that's harsh no I pay a mobile bill each
month so I could hear her on the voicemail
we eat suit in Georgia in the summer
taking a job in the middle of nowhere
it's all some kind of penance for
you not being able to save your wife
something like that tighten
your silly K you're that stupid
thank you hey you should do that
more often double [__] you twice
the beginning of a beautiful beautiful
friendship ah Rigs and Murdoch
Kleiner was murdered less than 24 hours ago
now his nephews aren't making deliveries it's
a lot of animal feed go to sleep the nightmare
start I miss their dad Thanks again nightmares
I lost my dad when I was a kid too him
my mom both episodes about loss yeah
and family my Memaw would read me Harry Potter
because Harry is told that his parents died in a
car accident but really they're Wizards your
dad trying to save him and make the world a
better place so that's when I started
to hate transgender people [Laughter]
here it is gunfu let's go
spooky get the girl's shoes on and
wait by the Cellar Door you hear
me yell you take off for the
woods and don't stop running
oh come on I can't take another Bull song
this is T-Bone Walker I thought t-ball was
white you sure he was black T-Mobile brunette
was white Walker was Black come on Finley
no way what's up Supernatural
[Music]
don't you cry no more no no no I
see it's a recap of Jack Reacher
now how to say all right guys
don't get there doing rock out
thank you Finley I've been
waiting for someone to say so
look Venezuelan
those guys have good hearing
I think their windows are down
oh
I gotta start sending these guys in
more than pairs oh this is intense yeah
out of the Fog
oh god oh man I'm gonna lose yes not too far east
from here maybe the first mile Mark you come to oh
Roscoe can't die not so
episode 8. when everybody dies
Nice Shot damn well done how'd you get such a good
aim in the night holy crap she knows
this place like the back of her hand
wolf
is that a flash grenade
oh
smart
oh Jesus oh no no let's go gory
still satisfying sure
let's do this I would wait like just
five more minutes yeah tops of these
trucks are made within vinyl to reduce the weight
God he knows everything yes a ton all the research
yes
so my two minute nap now it's time to get
back on the road this is having a smoke break
what a cut truck driver yeah
he's no truck driver oh jeez dude
I have point inspection it's
like a video game yeah oh
uh this is just that suspicious must be I
mean I guess it pays to be in this profession
back to immediate sleep said just wait five more
minutes wait until they're like in REM sleep you
know yeah you got time truck's empty it's a shell
game it's a dummy it wasn't shipping money out
what is he doing besides driving around for hours
to deliver nothing he's picking up we talked to
the people who are helping Joe the professors
they're unreachable not anymore Jack unreachable
I was looking for William Bryant
uh who don't even know how to say
good morning this morning woof I've lost
track of what this case is [Laughter]
so much happening yeah so they didn't get to both
hi reached my voicemail I'm dead
to Jack Reacher you were working with my brother
Joe I'm coming to New York now do everything I'm
about to tell you if you still want to be alive by
the time I get there that's the call you want to
receive can you give me just like 30 more minutes
been a long night I've been working on these kids
all night long it's like I should twisted our
ankle you rolled the ankle good didn't you
tell you what here's my ankle all aboard
the Conklin Express you okay ready one
two three get up there this was a ploy to get a
piggyback ride who's tougher in the Hubble ladies
Jack Reacher
and all these Venezuelans they keep
sending to try and kill you guys
all the people that misbehave and Mark grave
put you in your grave they're out cold it's
time for her to reveal some Secrets oh here
we go I don't know how we got here we aren't
bad people I know that but she knows some come on
they're knocked out cold say some [__] spill it
and everything he told you was
alive she already knows I have known
wait where my
where am I ever question my relationship with
my husband Mr Kleiner wanted to meet Paul
Paul was excited oh my God an actual flashback I
worked around towns that you've been interviewing
for positions at other institutions I would
love to throw cleaner Industries hat in the
ring that's incredibly flattering so turned
on I understand your hesitation something new
unexplored definitely illegal I got a big clients
in Venezuela see if this is a line of work that
might be up here alley two weeks pay one day's
work the American dream I'll never should have
gone to Venezuela you were able to move
that much currency in just a few hours
you sure this was all legal
a paper four times your current salary plus a 50
year-end kicker wow now these are animals that
are used to running as hard as fast as they can
one day they're locked in a stall and they Revolt
one day they just stop we pay them a lot of money
they know there's nothing they can do to escape
their fate and they realize that their new life
isn't that bad you know what I'm telling you this
because this is his new life that money that
you move today there's every cent of every
dollar was tied to an international counterfeiting
scheme of which you are now part whoa what a dick
I'm able to pay you so far above
market value because frankly
I am my own printing press jeez what a dick I
have your email your IP address your work product
you are in this now that's so messed up
is that entrapment I can't do this can't
do what can't get rich beyond your wildest
dreams for just banging away in your laptop
Jesus I'm going to protect you from yourself thank
you I'm Gonna Leave You in here for a
while what a master manipulation that
you don't run off and do anything stupid
so I've gotten every guest on the channel
don't knock the gate
you know he was a good man yeah poor Paul I hope
he ran away and he's just hiding I feel like he
could still be a lot like they've made so much
out of him being dead I feel like he's just hiding
oh that's hilarious
put him in there long enough to accept his fate uh
God you're gonna make him a witness to
this too please this is what happens to
you and your family oh they're gonna
have him witness all of this yeah
yeah that's like some Narco [__] if I've
seen narcos I would know the reference I'll
be with you until we can figure out
what to do next okay damn card's dead
yes sir laughs it's got to be very
rewarding to be able to do that
Richardson spent two weeks learning to stay
that long that one line I need a suit I don't
know I have enough fabric I don't have time for
jokes I need something now it's not that big yes
a little too big
interesting break them in what is he studying
studying I'm here to see my client Stephanie
Castillo I believe she's under your protection
I'll fill you in after she and I speak
it was wrong it's not season surrendered it's okay
she'll show up soon enough there really was
something in the water that reached your house huh
we were the only two academics in the U.S
specializing in the theoretical effects of
muc mass undetectable counterfeiting on
a global economic scale whoa jeez do you
know that 80 of existing U.S currency is
in hundred dollar bills eighty percent of
the money that I see every day it's not
C notes no where's all that cash abroad
underground economies drugs arms human trafficking
animals well there are security features but all
of that if someone is determined and talented
enough all of it can be replicated reverse
engineered they're not making money in Venezuela
and shipping out to the US they're making money
in the U.S and shipping out to Venezuela how
are you going to take down whoever's doing this
painfully sure what branch of the military were
you in army first lieutenant major Jack Reacher
I need your help Lieutenant my brother Joe Reacher
worked in secret service you can look them up but
you'll see I'm not one to waste time or make up
stories you made up a story I think about what
I have to hahaha it needs to be off the books
it needs to be quiet I Can Count On You Diaz
so yes sir God I gotta joined the military and a
loyalty for nothing no Brotherhood seems as rich
and rewarding I'm calling a favor anywhere don't
throw it out there's no point of throwing it dude
give it to like three homeless people
I was getting ready for a fight yeah
yeah I get that frame rate going
yeah frame rate fight foreign
Jack Runner Tom Cruise run
that's not exactly a Tom Cruise Room
go higher somewhere between Ezra Miller
nice graffiti in this episode
nice nice nice
oh yeah
hello oh yes yes come on use the tie let's go
that guy's right arm and this is messed up yeah oh
lovely oh my God that guy's head's
gonna crack All the Way backwards
paired in the sky
cool Jack Strangler it's New York they would do
nothing all those people living in those buildings
they would do nothing a big old rat just
come over and drag him away what an image
jeez boy oh boy oh boy hold on guys my phone was
blowing up is there something important I know
jeez gosh because everybody wants to
you know talk to you man everyone's
just excited for their great time each day
[__] annoying it's okay we can take them
out one by one everyone needs to leave me
alone including you guys everyone stop just
stop bothering me stop Greg stop Greg look at
me I want your view comments but not your actual
interaction right stop bothering me that's right
and please all of you people okay
okay I thought they figured out on the
truck when there was nothing in there
that they were delivering something to them
or that they were like picking something up
oh yeah they thought they were picking something
out yeah yeah but either either either way that's
that supports their idea that they're picking up
stuff from Venezuela but they're they're bringing
the money to them yeah so I don't know they said
there was nothing in there yeah so I'm like it's
not a little hole that he looked through that
one little hole I'm sure that big uh airtight
light tight box looks empty did you have a match
to throw in yeah that was interesting but uh
maybe it's the shell game or something maybe
they know that they're following the trucks
well I like the what's his name Hubble Hub
Hall yeah Paul Hubble Paul I think Chanel White
I laundered counterfeit money uh Paul Hubble and
Kleiner scene that was cool that was a really cool
one it does remind me of a lot of movies and stuff
that I've seen of specifically the era of like
Pablo Escobar times when they were handling Coke
traffic and all that stuff there's a kind of a bit
of that Vibe but it was neat to see the backstory
to that and you understand why Mrs Hubble would
not like her reasoning made a lot of sense to to
hide it especially because she too was in fear of
what could happen and you really do see this guy
was forced into a position that took advantage of
his good nature when he he was really just trying
to do the right thing and get a good job and then
to see what happened in prison as well I feel like
he could just be hiding I feel like he could just
be like run away and he's hiding somewhere I
feel like that's yeah there's a good likelihood
of that because like or she even knows she could
she could probably know I feel it is yeah I feel
like a just because yeah they keep assuring us
that he is dead but I don't know like especially
seeing that situation from his point of view I'm
like I would come back and come up with as many
contingency plans as possible because you just
have to imagine that this isn't going to stay uh
not not good but you know you can't imagine that
it's going to stay in such a position that he will
not be in danger forever you know yeah so I feel
like he could definitely be hiding now and maybe
he learned something from his time in this in this
Venezuelan experience yeah poor guy poor poor guy
he was just so cheery I'm like oh I'm gonna
make good money I'm good of a job man Skyler
The Godfather of margrave wants to work with me
how cool and that was the first time they show
kleiners truly being a ruthless villain who has
comeuppance I thought that was cool to actually
see like now this guy was a straight up evil dude
when I like that you have that part of the puzz
it's like we've been chasing him down trying to
pin the you know the guilt on Kleiner and and it's
like okay yeah he's involved big player not the
head player so that gives you kind of that like I
feel like in a mystery show like this or any kind
of procedural mystery I I think there's a certain
level of like you're trying to you know like
really throw the audience off by coming up with
the least likely you know culprit and so here it's
like okay that was likely and it made sense that
he'd be involved but it's not the answer to the
question yeah so I think in the finale Reacher's
gonna go to Venezuela rocking two machine
guns yeah it's just two freaking giant minions
he rides a helicopter and solo jumps Outlet to
crash into the horse farm ooh I love it Jack Rambo
let's go attack Rambo yeah and then he gets like a
bunch of uh ex-military folks just to kind of back
him up at random it'll be good this is Joe guy
seems great he's he seems like an American Saint
all around he was that sounds like the greatest
person who ever walked this Earth yeah he knew
what he knew and he knew what he didn't know
and everybody who worked with him reveres him
yeah they're willing to put their lives in
the future they may come out to be like the
greatest person ever like they put him on such
a pedestal there the imagery they put him on
makes you feel like he must be it must
have been the one and only person who was
more Superior in intelligence than than Jack
Jack already seems like a goddamn genius bulking
genius yeah I'm like what were they like if they
would have to solve some kind of mystery together
would it just be Jack trying
to keep up the whole time
Roscoe protecting that's cool it's cool that the
the show manages to do both of being a big mystery
like now we're in New York we've got the Venezuela
thing going on but it still keeps it in this like
small town Vibe like it still feels connected
to being part of a community a small community
instead of losing sight of that appeal I think
that's a really hard thing to that's a really
hard thing to do because those are two completely
different Vibes yeah and they managed to not lose
sight of that and yet I thought everything
in Margaret was all gravy until more gravy I
thought everything was all good in margrave until
recently but people are like you know kleiner's
like a Kleiner uh Finley is like why would you
stay here all this time like it seems like it's
nice as hell here yeah until all these murders
started happening it seems like a pretty idyllic
small town I mean people might be a little racist
which is bad and horrible to deal with but also
it seems like a pretty mellow existence out here
did not see that Trope coming of Finley's wife
dead I I usually can see something like that it's
usually a it's a common Trope but damn they have
me going really seemed like they had a divorce
yeah totally and that and and I liked I I like
the payoff to the mislead of him calling up and
leaving the message and and and the sweetness like
the heartbreaking sweetness of that of like I paid
for this phone bill just so I can hear her voice
I guess feel like there are cheaper ways to do
that but also that's like such a sweet kind of
heartbreaking thing unless you have to clear her
voicemail too yeah if he leaves too many does he
have to lock in and delete his own voicemails
damn it filled the Box up again lonely Thursday
yeah and that is a Trope too playing the
vote I mean I'm sure it happens in real life
um but that that is a Trope I've seen several
times too where they call the voicemail
you know to hear their voice again make you feel
like they're they're sending them a message or
connected to them and they did that and I'm
like oh they planted all the seeds for that
I love the way that scene went down
because Reacher doesn't go all soft
yeah it goes tough or wrong yeah it's like you
could tell he receives the information but he's
not about to make it yeah like something I'm sorry
right now like yeah okay like I get a little bit
more about you but also I'm still gonna but and
I love that thing with him swearing at the end
and you know double double F you twice a cute
moment out of it yeah sweet but Jack Reacher
style and Roscoe being a total badass real MVP
sure enough MVP of the show sharp shooting in
the woods at night with all them leaves and
shadows I don't think she's gonna die now
it could still happen they could still
castrate her and nail her to a wall
that would be an interesting scene it would be
an interesting scene but now I'm rooting for I'm
rooting for Orozco but I feel like she's gonna
walk out of this maybe with one more you know
pretty harsh bit of peril before it's
all said and done well there's too much
personal Stakes for her now too oh yeah
I mean you know her her direct kind of
involvement now but what's the deal with
what's the deal what's the deal with that
the mayor guy teal teal Bruce McGill he seems
like he actually gives a [__] uh yes there's
something it seems like he gives a [__] about
something like he's also corrupt but also gives
a [__] about some of this and like yeah I
can't tell what his deal is and I and and maybe
now maybe now it will turn out to be somewhere in
between I've been sitting here you know obviously
I think you're supposed to go like maybe he's not
he's either evil or he's just absolutely not and
it just kind of looks like he is but yeah I
don't I don't know with him and I think he's
good it's good casting because he's played so many
characters in these settings on both sides of the
line that I think just having him here kind of
muddies your expectation of what side it'll fall
on sure but I do I can see a version of this we're
just like yeah he's not like a police law they
made that deal about him you know not having like
police experience so maybe he's just running it
the way he knows how to run it and maybe that just
looks suspicious given the circumstances but I
like that you know all these things I can't really
tell I can't really like solidly conclude like
nah I'm still like committed to this Theory or
whatever yeah you know all the and and two I don't
know like that whole thing with uh the wound on on
that guy Greg's head with Roscoe going back into
the corn uh Corner uh information and and you know
the the Bejeweled staff looking like a Smoking Gun
like I almost wonder if that's the mislead but
then again I mean Kleiner was uh totally who they
suspected him of being so maybe it will turn out
that he is just one of these you know bad players
it's well drawn I don't know I can see it going a
number of ways yeah I think the characters are in
really well even like the random people who show
up for like a scene you know even like Neely and
this professor you know you you a big part of this
is that you're not going to get a lot of backstory
you're not going to get a lot of time with them
and you gotta have the sense that they're a fully
fleshed out character at the same time so it
requires like a solid actor to do it as well
but also enough Variety in the dialogue so that
way the the language of it speaks more volumes
in brevity than it does and you know Exposition so
I think that they did a really good job even that
Professor I'm like yeah I feel like this person's
like really been around the game for a while yeah
that feels like a real professional same thing
with Neely and so I think they do a really
excellent job uh with that Picard I'm not sure
about him it's the one characteristics I don't
really get the card character have full history
with the guy obviously seems like a guy he's just
like dude we still want to get fired for being
an FBI I don't know what to make of this either
because because he's like he's Charming yeah he's
charming and when he shows up you usually feel
pretty safe but also like the second he leaves
you like the good the assassination attempt goes
down so also I don't know I don't want there to be
a Twist where he's in on it or something but you
know they're all in on it everyone's the kids
the everyone's Venezuelan is that counterfeit
thing real I have to imagine it's based on some
kind of real I mean you know people counterfeit
so what do they print money I love to print money
oh yeah go to the mint how much easier would be
to print money yeah if you just then actually
earn that money yeah just cut out you know a
few pallets of Hondos and then your life is set
you know that'd be a crazy way to find that spot
yeah get your special it's probably like just
so military backed up oh sure oh sure the mint I
don't know like Yeah It's gotta be under lock and
key and and gun and knife and there's got to be a
moat and some quicksand and it's a very specific
type of paper yeah people counterfeit one time I
I paid one time when we're in Colorado um my mom
bought some Baskin Robbins and then the person had
to hail her down and and they beat her to a pulp
house criminals are down uh because apparently the
the 20 Bill she paid with wasn't a real 20 Bill
your mom's in on it she's in on it she's working
with the Venezuelans the mule she's bringing
slabs of fake Jackson's into the states she
could I think I think with the animals that's how
they're that's how they're awesome in the animal
feed bags that's that's the one detail unless that
turns out not to be I feel like that's the one dot
that they should be connecting it's like there's a
whole lot of animal feed I'm like what if it's not
animal feed but if it's just they gotta be hiding
it in the animal feed yeah or in the animals
[Music]
we gotta get these cows to [__] out the
money so we can take it back to Venezuela
you have like a lot of money in there but I don't
know they cut them open or whatever should be
disturbing I feel like I've seen something where
they do something like that um oh it's I'm sure
it's happened they hide something in animals yeah
oh oh then you're you're a true mule that way
but uh yeah it's good it's good it's keeping
the momentum man keeping the Intrigue keeping
the flavor alive keeping the good character
interactions solid ass show and then fight
scenes to keep your stimuli up yeah they're not
bored watching this show yeah where's my Carnage
where's my violence person my Primal expression
of Rage how can I watch Jack Reacher work out some
of his issues through violence that was a harsh
fight scene too that that fight scene on the uh
fire escape with the knife and the bicycle
wheel that's cool that's good I've seen harsher
I really did expect that guy's neck to like
completely snap backwards or dislocate her or
his head to come clean off I'm surprised Jack
Reacher was able to hang off of his necklace
without it like completely coming off did you
know when John Wick in that kitchen if I won
the when Kiana hits that guy who's on the kitchen
bar table and his neck snaps back a famous moment
yes that's that man actually is able to just
do that with his neck so they just threw it
into the fight because he's able to like
contort his neck like that wow so they're
like oh it's throwing into the fight
well yeah sure at that point like such
a such a icky thing to it looks like it's really
painful so yeah it's working in any way you can
all right ladies and gentlemen well what did you
think of the Super Mario Brothers movie I'll leave
your thoughts down below it's a me it's Jacob uh
subscribe click the Bell leave a like only got
two more episodes left hopefully we segue into
Luigi's Mansion afterwards yes Luigi Reacher
see you guys peace